Just to help us understand this, I want to actually also emphasize that
let's find these type of changes in an image, a real image like this one.
Of course, photo taken by my colleague Henry Christensen.
And let's look at various types of things within this image.
First, let's look at illumination changes.
Now if you look at this scene, there is,
of course, because lighting changes, there is shadows.
Those are illumination changes.
You can, of course, see a lot of different types of things.
There's not a lot of specular reflection here.
But that kind of tells us that there could be some changes happening in
the scene because if the, if the lights were on,
we would actually see a lot more illumination information.
We can separate out things like the word tech
because the color is different in front of that.
Also it has a specific shape that actually helps us also distinguish and
separate that out.
Depth discontinuity again comes in,
in this tower here is in front of something else.
We can look at that depth and see that this has to be in front so
there should be some sort of a discontinuity here at the tower.
Surface normal, basically again if you look at the steps here you
can see a lot of discontinuities because sometimes a surface normals of
these steps are changing around.
You can see this kinds of things across in the shape here.
Each one of these shapes basically has a different surface normal, and
it helps us kind of distinguish that.
Of course objects have well-defined boundaries.
This you know fire flume kind of things here or the roof decks here at different
objects, the windows and such, each one of them have different levels of detail.
And again that could be of course look for separately.
And of course also additionally reflectance change.
Now this is most visible here because and
I go down this roof top you can see the changes in colors.
A much more subtle change, but there is definitely a reflectance change here.
That starts telling me that this is a different shape and
of course there is of course much changes in this one too.
Hopefully this helps you try to start thinking about how we can actually look
for these types of changes in real images.